to get along here there's the cardigan i
can see it and everything all right
all right we'll get going here in three
and
two this morning we're taking a look
in your business and we're gonna mix in
some entertainment this time around as
we are joined now by vegas chamber
president and ceo mary beth seawall
and special guest las vegas headliner
frankie moreno
thank you both for joining us to talk
about what's happening in las vegas
right now
and mary beth let's get right into
things the annual vegas preview comes up
on thursday it's on the 21st
what's on the agenda thank you so much
john yes we are so excited
preview las vegas is on 121 21
and we are doubling down on vegas this
this next year you know
at preview the business community really
gets an opportunity to learn what's
ahead for the economy so that they can
plan for the coming year
you see it there it's a virtual event
it's the first time we've ever gone all
virtual
and we're just super excited because you
know 2020 was an incredibly challenging
year for so many people
and that's why we chose the theme
doubling down on las vegas and that's
why we have frankie with us
and we'll get to him here in just a
second but it's really a great
opportunity for experts and thought
leaders to talk about
important business issues as you know
and exciting opportunities that can
really
drive growth and job creation for las
vegas so
we're just really excited we've got some
we've got some familiar faces and we
also have some brand new faces
well mary beth before we get any further
let's talk just about the economic
landscape right now
in las vegas um obviously 2020 has been
challenging we're just now getting
started
in 2021 what needs to happen
to spark the return essentially of what
is driving las vegas
well you know john it has been an
incredibly challenging year economically
for our small businesses our medium size
and our large businesses alike
and that's one of the reasons why we
have steve hill he's the president of
the las vegas convention and visitors
authority
he's going to do a fireside chat with
contessa brewer you might remember her
she might know her from cnbc they're
going to talk about what's ahead for
tourism
uh you know the conventions and tourism
is the core of our economy
so steve's going to share both the
outlook for tourism as well
as well as a lot of the challenges that
the industry faces and how vegas is so
well positioned to attract those
visitors
once covid cases go down so um
you know convention and tourism is huge
and then we also have derrick stevens
really excited to feature him he's the
ceo of the d
and circa and he's going to talk about
why he's so bullish on las vegas and
what he's experiencing in his business
seems like getting vaccines out it would
be a crucial part not only from a health
standpoint mary beth but also
from an economic standpoint the the more
people who are vaccinated from the
coronavirus
the easier it is to do business
absolutely
you know we're really looking forward to
gearing up
uh the the vaccines more in across the
entire state
and really get literally giving a shot
in the arm to
both our our citizens and the economy as
well
all right so frankie you've been sitting
there patiently obviously the the theme
here for the vegas preview the doubling
down
uh it's been hard for entertainers right
now obviously in las vegas
uh trying to find employment trying to
make a buck here
what's it been like for you and talk
about your involvement here in the vegas
preview
i mean it's it's definitely a whole
different thing you know so
we used to play all the time and a lot
of tourings whenever i wasn't playing in
vegas we'd be touring and we just
we had european tours set up and
everything that uh of course did not
happen
but um right away i guess in march or
april right after lockdown
my first instinct was well i've got some
time let me
let me write music and i started just
utilizing the time
i figured you know whenever this does
open where we play again
i don't want to go back out and just do
the same show the same songs
same clothes like let's start building
it all new and
and and and working on that and kind of
jumped in that real quick and we were
releasing a song
every single week we've been uncon you
know still consistently doing that and
giving all the uh proceeds to the coven
19 relief fund
a lot of entertainers are doing that too
frankie uh you've got the song doubling
down on vegas that'll be released
at the vegas preview i guess we all have
to kind of be optimistic for 2021 but
from an entertainment standpoint
uh how much drive is there right now to
try and get back on stage
well i mean i think it i think it's just
more of just a thing of just just
you know having the optimism and and
where you know you can't you can't just
expect it to go back to
uh just like you know like it's march
17th right we can't just go back as a
performer to
what it was i i think it's going to be
different it's going to be
a new way of approaching it and you know
i'm excited to see what it is going to
be there's there's definitely
it's going to be something and i'm not
exactly sure what
but um but i'm i'm ready for whatever it
is and that's why
it's nice to get involved with the
chamber here to do this song
because uh it it brings a little bit you
know makes everybody remember like oh
yeah we are
we are kind of badass in vegas you know
well final question mary beth just to
circle back a little bit the legislative
sessions on the horizon there's going to
be a lot of
budget cuts budget discussions up there
what are some of the main
things that you and others in the
business industry are going to try and
focus on
in carson city you know john we're
focusing on
really looking out for our businesses
there are more than 800
bill draft requests that are coming out
already
the vegas chamber is actively tracking
more than 500 of those
and you know there's a lot of concern
number one that the legislation that's
being considered will be very
dangerous to our businesses and our
economy
across the entire state of nevada and so
the vegas chamber
is passionately advocating on behalf on
behalf of our businesses
but the other thing john is that as
you'll recall the last
first and second special sessions were
not open to the public
and it makes it extremely challenging
for
our citizens across the state to have a
voice at the legislature and so that's
one of our big concerns as well is that
because of covid you know no one is
going to be able
or allowed to go into the state
legislature and so it makes it very
difficult for our citizens to actually
communicate and use their voice with our
legislators so
that's another thing that the chamber is
going to be watching out for as well and
i know just mary beth
speaking with lawmakers myself they're
trying to mitigate that as much as they
can as well given the circumstances
good luck with the vegas preview both of
you frankie and mary beth thank you for
joining us again to talk about what's in
our business here
and we'll catch up with you again later
thank you